hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll if
you are a working cosmologist and you're
studying the cosmic microwave background
in particular how density perturbations
in the microwave background grow into
galaxies and large-scale structure Etc
one of the first things you have to
learn about is matter Falls in to some
overdense region and then photons stream
out and the photons streaming out damp
the oscillations and the growth of
structure in that pre-cmb era this
phenomenon is called Silk damping after
today's guest Joseph silk who first
wrote about it in 1968 in a paper on
Galaxy formation in the cosmic
background radiation pretty amazing when
you think that we only discovered the
cosmic microwave background radiation in
1965. Joe silk has gone on to be a
leading theoretical cosmologist for
decades now I've known him for a long
time and for example after we discovered
the anisanthropies in the cosmic
microwave background from the Kobe
satellite in 1992 it was clear that Joe
Silk's group at Berkeley at the time was
one of the very small number of leading
places which was training up young
people to tackle this new set of puzzles
so slightly surprising to me when Joe
recently gave a colloquium at Johns
Hopkins and it was not about recent
wrinkles in cosmological theory it was a
sales pitch for going back to the moon
and building telescopes there now
obviously there is a relationship here
any working cosmologist wants more data
better data and the moon provides an
excellent place to build telescopes and
get more cosmological data but the
thoroughness of the case that Joe made
and the interest in all the different
aspects of it I thought was very
impressive in fact I learned thereafter
that Joe has a new book out called back
to the moon the next giant leap for
humankind where he takes very seriously
the idea that not only should we travel
back to the Moon in our little
spaceships we should put people there
have a a settlement and do science he
makes a very explicit case for the
different kinds of telescopes that you
can build and also for other benefits of
being on the moon including mining Rare
Earth elements and things like that so
this is a very fun conversation because
it's a intersection right of science
issues you know why can't we just build
a big telescope on Earth or in orbit or
whatever what's so special about the
moon but also practical technological
and political issues who's going to do
this do we have the money what is the
case for for people who don't
necessarily care a lot about modern
cosmology and you know I think
it's kind of persuasive I think that you
know the case is actually pretty darn
good
um opinions May differ that's perfectly
okay but it is something that the human
race is going to be confronted with the
possibility the opportunity to do in the
near term future so I'm happy that we're
thinking about it at a high level let's
go
[Music]
Joe silk welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you for inviting me you
know I was in the audience for a
colloquium that you gave at Johns
Hopkins where we are colleagues and I
I've known you for decades now as a
famous accomplished theoretical
cosmologist and here you are advocating
to travel to the Moon so I presume there
is some story there or at least there's
some I know there's an intellectual
Connection in terms of the science that
can be done but how did you in
particular decide that building
telescopes on the moon was was what you
really wanted to put some effort into
well I I was getting very frustrated
with the progress in cosmology that I
was seeing around me
um my colleagues are um have made it
immense advances in cosmology and I
began in the field which is I guess
maybe half a century ago I had to think
of it but there were uncertainties in
measuring
parameters such as the Hubble constant
other things which enormous 50
uncertainty and we live with that you
know we spent our early careers debating
you know uh issues of 50 uncertainty
back is it two unknowns yeah suddenly
over the past decade as we've brought in
much more precise surveys especially
purchasing galaxies and we've made
enormous use of the microwave background
also as a cosmological tool the
fluctuations in that background uh
errors our systematics now have dropped
to maybe two percent
um but it seems that the same questions
are still plaguing us we
um you know how the law begin and
um
you know what is the meaning of it all
the universe does seem to be
accelerating we've learned that from
this enormously improved data but what
does that mean where does all that come
from and so we're hoping uh that with
the next generation of surveys with
bigger and better telescopes my
colleagues are hoping at least they'll
get some answers but I'm very very
pessimistic because what I've seen is
that over the years I've been in the
field
um we have this outrageous hypothesis at
the beginning from the Metro Josh
lemitra that there was a cosmological
constant universe is accelerating at the
moment and
we didn't understand it at the time we
still don't understand it but all the
recent studies Converge on Limitless of
visual hypothesis the constant uh and uh
you know you need to see some deviations
to understand the physics better to see
what what's really going on and I saw no
Prospect in not just the current surveys
but the next generation of surveys
actually making real progress so because
obviously is Convergence
uh so I decided that we're going to do
something radically different to make a
break from here and
um eventually the scenes that um putting
telescopes on the moon is going to be
the way to do that over the long term
that'll be the next step forward in
cosmology I think I mean it's a
fascinating answer which I didn't
anticipate so it all comes from
the cosmological constant problem and
the issues that it arises I mean you're
right that cosmology is often inspired
by these very big questions why are we
here how did it all begin and then the
working cosmologist ends up measuring
the amplitude of density fluctuations to
some percent or something like that I
mean do you think that there is this
kind of prospect for answering those
bigger questions if we just get better
telescopes
well let's see it's more than just the
causative constant because we have to go
back also to the beginning
um which is now pretty much to everyone
in the field theory of inflation is the
most significant advantage of cosmology
since the time of Joshua Metra in um
basically you know a century but we have
no proof we don't understand how
inflation really began
now there is
um a fast-stating hypothesis that we're
trying to test namely that as inflation
came to an end it generated
gravitational wave modes that left their
imprint to the microwave background
so we have many experiments beautiful
experiments set up to look for those and
no doubt they will give us some answers
in 10 years but the problem is that
there is absolutely no guarantee they
will achieve success because the
predicted value of this Distortion is
totally uncertain if we're lucky or
optimistic then find it they'll find the
missing proof but the chances are it
could be almost at any level
and so my view is why don't we do some
cosmology with a guaranteed return which
will tell us the answer
and so that that's what really drove me
towards um this next stage which I can
tell you about to do with doing
something on the moon yeah no we'll
definitely get there but I'm just
intrigued to ask one more question along
these lines while I have you here which
is what is the probability that you
personally would put on inflation or
something very much like inflation being
true in the real world
I would
um like to think it's 50 okay it's such
a
a compelling Theory to me but it also
raises questions as to how it began so
for that reason I won't go all the way
to a higher probability and it's so
compelling that I wouldn't give it a
much lower one so 50 I think it's a fair
your answer which means you'll better do
a lot of work to get any better that is
exactly my probability so I'm very glad
that we're on uh agreement here I think
that a lot of our colleagues put it a
lot higher which which worries me a
little bit sometimes
so going back to the Moon then uh that's
a big thing we've been to the Moon once
before the Apollo missions Etc why don't
you set some context by telling us what
the previous Moon missions accomplished
and you know why they ended what what's
different now it was a long time ago it
was 50 years ago
although that's exactly right I mean the
Apollo
um Reign the Apollo accomplishments were
marvelous actually they were inspired by
JFK of course he he had this um driving
ambition to demonstrate to the world
that he could outspeed the Russians
having been taken aback by that at the
time and he did it amazingly in in half
a decade and the budget they put into
that was enormous it was you know a
significant fraction of our gross
national product in the US
so we'll never see days like that again
but nevertheless
um it's clear uh as time has gone on
that
we want to go back to the moment because
that is our next major Frontier in
scientific exploration for many reasons
and if we put telescopes on the moon I
think we can answer some really
incredible questions about the universe
and perhaps the the biggest question of
all is what was there out there before
there were any stars before there any
galaxies and we call that area
era the Dark Ages and I think we can
ultimately penetrate the Dark Ages
only from the Moon
and do I remember correctly reading that
at the peak of Apollo
NASA's budget was something like four
percent of the U.S total budget and now
it's more like 0.4 percent
that that's that's absolutely correct
but you must remember that 0.4 percent
is still an awful lot of money and it's
more than enough to finance the um our
team is program which is the current
program to get
um humans back on the moon and more than
just back on the moon but to build a
space station around the moon and do
many other things well let's let's fill
in some of that because I'm not actually
up on it so the Artemis program is is
happening right like NASA is doing it
and it involves boots on the moon
that's exactly right so the first goal
is to get boots on the moon
um and the interesting thing that is
spurring this along uh uh at Great
intensity it's China is doing exactly
the same thing they have a program to
have the first astronauts back on the
moon in
2026 and NASA wants to match that and if
anything get there before the Chinese
and it's not a question of getting um
just anybody on the Merlin both
countries uh announced that they want to
get the first woman on the moon
and among the astronauts in training uh
on the NASA Issa side there are even
Nationals of color and even one disabled
astronaut so I think that's you know our
boundaries are changing but it'll be
much more than putting astronauts on the
moon of course but that's that's the
first step and you mentioned a a space
station I've heard about this there's
the lunar Gateway that is going to be in
orbit around the Moon rather than orbit
around the Earth
that's correct so the uh that's the next
step and the reason is that um uh
you wanted to go to build a facility
from which you can easily land on the
moon without creating too much Havoc
um in lunar dust Etc
um you know come it's so much easier
than going directly from the earth we
have a space station with pods in from
which you can send Landers down to the
circus that's how we did the Apollo
program right we send an orbit around
the Moon which dropped the pods onto the
surface so it's the same idea it and
from this orbiting space station we'll
be dropping that that'll be where the
astronauts reside at first but one could
just make that a a more homely sort of
place a safer place to live than
initially on the surface of the Moon and
so that's where they'll be and we'll
have um odds coming down the long-term
goal of the space station will also be
to launch a Rockets um into
interplanetary space further afield and
also back to Earth of course so it'll be
a major hub for exploration but we'll
start off in orbit around the Moon
because that's such a much easier place
to uh to develop and just to calibrate
our expectations here this is all stuff
on the NASA side that is in the budget
right this is not just a plan that
they're dreaming up and trying to sell
to Congress this is the ongoing stuff is
happening for this project
that's correct and this all comes out of
the um the standard NASA budget it's
it's an infraction of course
not so much of the Lesser budget but of
the total GDP but this is enough to keep
the whole our team is program going the
next decades
are there other countries besides the US
and China who are interested in this
it's an amazing race at the moment uh
between
the primary players of the US and China
is there they have so far the largest
spacecraft and the and the largest
manned
um crude space programs but smaller
spacecraft are being launched by many
other countries they're driven actually
by the availability in the past
recent years of commercial launches
which are eager to expand their Horizons
the future exportation at the moon and
so they are available and they're being
sponsored by by not just by NASA to
develop spacecraft but also they're
available on the international scene for
any country to to buy a launch uh
vehicle uh temp to use one to send stuff
to the moon but in the past three months
alone
there have been
um
launches by Israel and by the United
Arab Emirates both of which were
successful but they're being playing
they're going to repeat them and they
were designed to send small lunar Rovers
to the Moon to do
um surveying of terrain
that incidentally is what we have to be
doing now thinking of because one of the
major issues is going to be now to use
the moon have exploited the moon and for
that we need information and that means
basically doing sort of the angle of the
Moon both from satellites and from
on-site Rovers and when you mentioned
the commercial commercial spacecraft
this is I presume SpaceX blue origin
companies like that
yes there are there are probably a dozen
small companies now
um not just um in the US but one or two
are in Japan Etc which are trying to
make
um a commercial business out of the Moon
of course you know the Moon is very high
on the list of um of tourist
destinations and so that will be another
goal as well as exploitation of the
surface and the moon or Resort resources
that we could use on the Earth would you
go as a tourist to the Moon if you could
afford it
um
were I much younger yes I jump at the
thought but yeah you know I don't think
my Mobility would get me uh well even
though the gravity is lower that would
help a bit but I gotta get there first
though yeah so but it's interesting
because I guess that is a a consequence
of these private companies building
their own space Vehicles is that other
countries can get into the game much
more easily as long as they have money
they don't need the technological
know-how necessarily
yeah so what's quite amazing is that the
cost is coming down rapidly of these uh
transport vehicles that take us to the
moon the commercial industry uh is very
good now at modest payloads of tons a
few tons perhaps
um the major payloads were shown that
just for the moment in the domain of
starex of NASA of China Russia too which
can carry tens of tons of payload those
also are rapidly developing and vanilla
effect all of this is the cost per the
kilogram of the delivery to the moon is
going down rapidly so it's a whole new
ball game for uh uh doing doing things
on the moon yeah and so let's just segue
into what we want to do on the Moon I
mean obviously the skies are dark and
clear uh but tell us more in some more
detail like what what is the call for uh
for cosmology and astrophysics
well before we do that there is
competition before we get to science
science is a is at the back of the queue
there's no question of that but let me
tell you what what the major driver is
right now to go to the moon and that is
to um
exploit the moon to do mining on the
moon now the mining is really really
simple to start with okay because all we
want to mine is ice
amazingly
um there are craters near the poles of
them and many craters
which are in permanent shadow that they
have such high rims the Sun never gets
too high in the Horizon because they're
Polo they do the poles
um or too low and so they're very cold
in fact the temperature measured in
these dark craters to be as low as 30
degrees Kelvin or absolutely zero which
is incredible which is great for
astronomers it's also great for rice and
what was discovered a decade ago was
that these craters are full of ice many
of them
so what do you do with the ice well the
idea is it's got two immensely important
uses one is you can break it down into
hydrogen oxygen liquefy the two we have
Rocket Fuel and then you also have
oxygen but
um habitat use and so suddenly we can
now imagine designing and we have energy
sources obviously from the uh from the
hydrogen too so now we can obviously
design habitations on the surface of the
Moon aiming at exploiting the dark
craters not only Shadow creators near
near the poles of the moon so that's the
first goal and that's a major step
because that will be the key to doing
everything else on the moon
do we know how much water ice there is
um it's hard to be totally quantitative
but our leaders the agencies are
convinced there's more than enough just
apply a rocket fuel for a very long time
so that that
they're eager to exploit that very
exactly but but overall
um maybe this is jumping ahead a bit but
if we want to build things on the moon
we are going to have to Crate up a lot
of
tonnage of material from the Earth to
the Moon right like we presumably we
can't mine iron very easily
in fact the lunar regulus is a very rich
source of all the elements she might
need to
um for example build Electronics even
you can easily make cement with lunar
dust and water and and do structures on
the moon so everything is in place and
it is in village
over the next decade or tune will be
manufacturing locally on the moon so you
will have to carry everything to them
and one could do more or less anything
one wants with local materials so that's
that's part of the planning does that
include
um the the raw materials for breathable
air
indeed yes but basically you have the
ice and the oxygen that so that will
give us the atmosphere we need and you
can you know get enough you know gases
from lunar regulator to to mix through
the oxygen to make it safer and that's
uh
so to be done so let's I want to ask
more details about that but let's let's
get the motivation more more explicit
here
um I presume that as an astronomer
cosmologist you want to build telescopes
Are there specific kinds of telescopes
that are especially better on the moon
than just say in orbit I mean we we're
doing pretty well with jwsd which is it
not on the moon
right so the problem is
um jwst is a pretty small telescope
really I mean eight meters it's not even
that we can build larger ones on the
earth actually gone to 39 meters as the
current large sum of the construction
therefore with the limit we'll never
build a bigger one the problem is that
um
what you want to do is to ideally
look very far away with your telescopes
but also look in detail even nearby with
the incredibly high resolution both in
terms of the spectrum and the light
Gathering Power and it turns out that to
really do a good job of that you need a
much larger telescope than we can
currently launch into space
and so let me give you the optimal
example of this which is
um if you could imagine building a
telescope that was one kilometer across
on and you can only do that on the moon
very hard in space too but in principle
you can go to a dark grader and fill the
Creator with them with mirrors and
combine the beams Etc we put sort of
ways of doing this
and if you could combine those beams
together and I can explain how that
sound in a second but the first point is
that with such a huge diameter an
incredible resolution
suddenly you could get a resolution of
millionths of a second of Arc that
millions of times better than you can do
on the Earth
just limited by the size that telescope
actually
and once you get that sort of resolution
um you can imagine looking at um nearby
planets planets that are twins of the
earth actually around nearby stars stars
tens or hundreds of light years away and
with that Exquisite resolution you could
study these planets some of which are
twins of the earth actually and we have
no idea what's going on in those parts
at the moment but with this resolution
you could look at the cloud cover when
you look at the mountaintops you could
see the glimmering of the oceans against
uh sunlight from the host star you could
look with spectroscopy into the
atmosphere in detail the signs of um
lifelike indicators methane or whatever
for example or pollution from you know
uh industrial or even nuclear fuels that
sort of thing tiny amounts you could
suddenly see what provided you had a big
enough telescope so in some sense a big
telescope is the key
to really answer you one of the biggest
questions we have maybe are we alone in
the universe to me that's one of the
most exciting goals and then just to
finish it you wonder how on Earth you do
this well you go to a dark creature
which already is very cold so it has
it's a great place to build telescopes
it's very dark all the time and you
string your camera from the rims of the
crater okay and so you build telescopes
in on the Basin to basically all Focus
their Beam at the camera is sprung from
the rim and the only challenge really is
to combine those beams and that's a
simple
question of um basically quantum physics
really because we're finally learning
we've done this now for for essentially
two telescopes on the earth uh we now
would have to do this to hundreds of
them to combine beams together to bring
to make them coherent so all these many
small telescopes that give me the
equivalent of one big one but that is
possible it's technologically possible
it means developing much better being
combined us with with ideas from quantum
physics but we're on the way to doing
that so I I could see that in 10 20 30
years well a telescope like this could
answer one of our biggest problems
that's great and uh just to try to dig
into the details a little bit more for
the audience uh or maybe for me and I'm
the proxy for the audience I know that
in radio astronomy uh a technique like
this is often used right where we use
different individual dishes and combine
them into one big telescope that's
harder to do more rare to do in Optical
or infrared astronomy because the
wavelength of the light is shorter I
presume uh is there is that it is there
more more to it than that no there's
more to it on the the other problem is
the atmosphere the Earth's atmosphere it
makes it incredibly difficult because it
gives you um scattering the turbulence
Etc in the atmosphere invisible that
means it's incredibly hard to um uh to
co to cohere these beams together long
wavelengths it's easier a short Blends
it becomes almost impossible which is
the great advantage of going to the Moon
where you have no atmosphere
so that makes a huge difference it
doesn't mean to say it's easy to do but
it's going to make it
um
a challenging project but I think we can
do it so that that answers the other
question I had is the primary advantage
of the Moon I mean one of them is
obviously the atmosphere is not there
but another one presumably is that
there's less gravity so maybe it's
easier to build a giant structure
without it you know collapsing under the
force of gravity is that a benefit at
all or am I being fanciful that's
exactly right and I I'm sure that
um uh
this idea of using a natural crater to
combine a lot of small tulips telescopes
together that's one design option
another one might be to build a coherent
much larger telescope than anything we
can build on the Earth
because there are no winds to shake the
structure gravity is much lower you
would be able to support the structures
much more easily so that would be
another another direction to go in and
we will need to discuss certain enormous
details and Designs the pros and cons
probably we'll end up with both
approaches eventually
is the reason to use a single crater if
we're going to have many dishes and
physical dishes and then combine them
together into one effective telescope uh
I'm wondering why we don't just scatter
them all over the moon rather than
putting them in a crater but maybe it's
just colder in the crater
yeah and it's also dark all the time so
that should be different so but it's
colder and um I mean the extremes of
temperature when you're not in the
craterial or the women are enormous they
go from you know incredible heat
incredible cold and it's very hard to
design a structure that can operate you
know on with a high sensitivity under
those extreme conditions whereas in a
dark crater
uh you have much more control over the
thermal environment
so it's a much more stable situation
where you'd want to build your
telescopes I was going to say maybe it's
also just hard to do it in a very cold
environment but presumably satellites
and existing orbital telescopes do that
all the time
that's right and you know one would be
you know working with robots on the
moment I'm sure as well so it wouldn't
necessarily need a you know a human
presence right at the telescope
certainly for installation you might but
eventually he would not so you you've
made a very good evocative case for
super high resolution pictures of
earth-like planets elsewhere so let's
you know let our hair down a little bit
uh what do you think we're gonna see do
you think we're gonna see life on a
whole bunch of other planets do you
think that we'll see intelligent life
uh look we have no idea uh the problem
is that um
you know we've theorized a lot of the
origins of life we simply don't
understand it
um there are a number of theories out
there you know re ranging from you know
Origins and some
muddy shallow Arts emotions Etc life
emerging
Etc but you know all this is is just a
guess
um what we only have one example
actually on the earth
um we are eager to go to Mars for a very
good reason but we know once upon a time
that had an atmosphere that had flowing
water it's pretty arid now there's no
evidence Signs of Life on Mars we
haven't seen them yet but the thought is
if we go to Mars and dig deep maybe
we'll find some you know some dried
bacteria or something or perhaps even
more that we let me give us Clues but
right now we have nothing another option
is
um there are one or two moons one in
particular around Saturn with Enceladus
which is covered in ice but we know that
beneath that ice there are water oceans
and we found that out by a recent
satellite our recent Mission shooting a
probing and we saw the water splash out
what an amazing experience so that ocean
cold ocean is another place where we're
going to go back to and look for life
but frankly I can't imagine that that
would be you know
even if we found something it would be
terribly interesting from this question
of life in the year as Etc
so we have to do that of course but I
think our best bet is to look for
planets that are essentially like the
Earth but let's say of Rocky cores they
have atmospheres they're not too far
from the Hostile which is like the Sun
not too close so they wouldn't get you
know they wouldn't be burnt to a cindery
really on the surface and so we now know
that
um there are many such planets our best
estimate is billions in the Milky Way
and so all of these are potential sites
of life but because we have no idea
where the chances of life is one in a
billion or one hundreds of billions or
maybe 100 it's all open we have to look
and so the way we look is we try to get
a sample of these exoplanets and um
the trouble is that with a small
telescope such as the one that our
agencies are planning to do life
searches uh like the best one that we
have that came out of a recent study was
a six meter telescope designed to get
Exquisite images of the atmospheres of
nearby exoplanets so it had very high
resolution it has a device for shielding
the blinding light from the Star so you
can actually see the planet into some
extent against the stock the trouble is
with a six meter telescope you have a
sample of probably 20 exoplanets around
the nearest stars that you could
have the sensitive to really study and
that simply is not enough so my dream is
that you know with a um let's say a
hundred meter telescope on the moon or a
larger one would suddenly improve that
sample from you know tens thousands of
exoplanets and improve our odds of
finding something interesting so that's
the reason we want to build bigger
telescopes and we can best do that from
the Moon it would not be affordable
anywhere else actually and
I I know this is not exactly on the the
science point but I I wonder whether we
really appreciate the effect it will
have on our psyche and our self-image as
human beings when we do find that there
is life on other planets is it going to
be just we or are we so prepared for it
have we priced it in or is it going to
be a shock to the system
um I think over the years we price this
in with all our uh you know warnings
about UFOs and the hike so I think
people a certain subset of population
are ready for this I would say uh most
of us perhaps are not but uh yeah uh and
the chances are of course if you do find
something interesting you know we're
discussing something many light years
away from us so it's hard to see any uh
you know dramatic communication right
and it's very unlikely just to put a cap
on this it's it it's easy to imagine
extraordinarily primitive life right
single-celled organisms whatever and
maybe it's possible to imagine super
Advanced life that has gone Way Beyond
us because they've been technological
for a billion years now but it's very
unlikely we will find peers out there in
our Galactic neighborhood nearby
that's probably right it'll be one
extreme or the other I think I would
agree with that and that the worrying
thing is of course is that when we try
to ex rapidly to life around stars that
have been around for billions of years
longer than our sun uh any like they
would have had a billion years or so
Advanced on the earth for making life
the trouble is we have no idea whether
that life would have survived that that
million years but you know there are so
many potential catastrophes where
imagine we're going through on the earth
now who knows what how how challenging
that would be over longer time scale so
on the other end it's possible of course
is a sort of a science fiction writers
tell us that it couldn't be a very uh
intriguing and highly Advanced learned
life I guess we're open to to this do
you have a favorite answer to Enrico
fermi's question about where all the
aliens are
um I I fear for the worse that they're
simply they're incredibly rare and that
yeah
that's not the worst the worst is that
they're common and they always blow each
other up or something like that right
yes okay okay of course is uh which is
another worry if we have right too far
in finding them yeah but it's not just
exoplanets in life that we'd be looking
for I mean we started off by talking
about cosmology so like what would these
giant telescopes do for the working
cosmologist
well okay so let me turn to the other
aspect of telescopes which is Radio
astronomy so the advantage of uh doing
radio is that you can um penetrate the
universe and see what happened before
the first Stars so let me explain why
that is
um galaxies are made of gas clouds that
come together and so these gas clouds
are the building blocks of the universe
and we know roughly that they wrote you
know each one probably must weigh a
million solar masses a million times the
mass and certain and that's simply
because you need a certain amount of
gravity there for them to condense as
gas clouds and that's our best
calculation of how big they should be
and so then you do these very simple
estimate which says well we know that
our Milky Way galaxy uh is many billions
of times the mass of the Sun that's its
mass therefore it must have formed from
millions of these smaller gas clouds
they are the building blocks that's the
raw material from which we were made and
so
how on Earth do you find these things
well the idea is you look back in time
before the first Galaxy before the first
stars and you look for gas clouds now
the way you would do that is you use the
tool of the astronomers to measure
hydrogen gas
which is a 21 centimeter line of atomic
hydrogen
and so that
um can be excited
um and um gives you an absorption or an
emission set of excited the the
um it's the electron spin levels that
are exciting and de-excited so they give
you the remission or if they're excited
they will give you an absorption in
something distant okay some background
radiation so that's the idea the trouble
is if you want to look at this radiation
from way back in the past it's highly
about shifted so for 21 centimeters you
suddenly have to start thinking about 10
meters because that's roughly how far
back you want to go to get to where the
first clouds were that made the first
galaxies and there should be many many
of them
now you can't go back too far because
you run into the microwave background
and that sort of mixes everything
together but it's when the background
radiation cools down a zeros expands but
the matter then cools down even further
and so you can see it as a cold Shadow
against the cosmic microwave background
so that's the idea and the typical
wavelength will be tens of meters
okay so that tells you what you're going
to look for a singular Shadow against
the fossil radiation from The Big Bang
but you can only
do that in a place where the radio
environment the radio astronomical
signals can get to us the trouble is on
the earth we have an ionosphere which um
surrounds us you hear that when you
listen into the radio you turn between
stations you hear this crackle and pop
right
um that's all from the ionosphere and
when you look at low frequency radio
waves 10 meter-ish wet radio waves uh
the eye honestly is opaque nothing can
get to us from the distant Universe it
just bounces off the ionosphere so what
do you do what do you go to somewhere
where there's no way I understand so you
go into space
that's fine when you go into space which
we're certainly doing that the trouble
is the Earth is a huge
source of radio emission
from things like FM stations from cell
phones Maritime Radars you name it space
is not so simple if you want to look for
this signal from the beginning so
there's only one place that is nearby
not so nearby but it's The Far Side of
the Moon and it turns out The Far Side
of the Moon
is the most radio quiet place in the
entire inner solar system because the
Earth just doesn't shine there in radio
sense okay so you'll block completely so
our our Dream now and it's more than a
dream actually is to put radio
telescopes From The Far Side of the Moon
now the first remark is that these are
really simple radio telescopes they're
just like your TV antennas I mean
nothing more they're what we call
dipoles because metal wires basically
which you have to correlate together
with wires or cables or something but
and put the signal together and then you
pin the cigarette to an opening
satellite which means it back to work
for example so that's the sort of thing
we're going to start off doing
and if we have um enough sensitivity
then that will give us a glimpse of the
Dark Ages of these clowns that were
there before the first galaxies and so
that we think is the New Horizon for
astronomy it's totally unexplored
they're actually the New Frontier if you
like we haven't been there yet we're
going to go there and then we're going
to learn amazing stuff let me go there
well we do have these hints from jwst
that there are galaxies that are younger
than we thought and bigger than we
thought they're very they assemble very
early and some people are worried or
wondered whether this is a challenge to
our models of Galaxy formation do you
think that that's a real worry or just
like an inducement to learn more
well I I think the the the basis of all
this the problem with all of this is
that we do not have a theory of how
stars form and what we're looking at is
the consequence of star formation these
radius and galaxies sleep based almost
all our knowledge of star information
what we measure in the military way and
very nearby galaxies and to extrapolate
there
from a current Vista point of 10 billion
years after the big bang back to near
the beginning 100 million years after is
a really dangerous and toxic thing to do
you have no idea what what we're doing
actually so what we can do is observe of
course and we do see things that seem
slightly strange far away not what we
had predicted
but I think at this point the jury is
out we just don't know if this is due to
some slight increased efficiency of
making Stars maybe there were more
massive stars back then at the beginning
of the Galaxy all these things are
postulated or is it something radically
new
um extra objects forming galaxies known
the words expected so it's very
dangerous to say that there is something
radically new going on before you fully
understand the standard physics the the
simple explanations that we don't have
have by far not mastered at all yet it's
all I can say about this is that we need
a lot more data and the data is going to
come in the next year or two and with
all that data we're certainly not have
samples of tens of these galaxies yeah
what we have now we'll have hundreds
thousands hundreds of thousands and only
then we'll be able to come to a more
definitive statement about whether
what's going on back then you don't want
to panic right away you want to just
collect more data
absolutely it's uh panicking will uh
you'll be wasting your time that's mine
good I mean I think these are uh
compelling cases for the exoplanets high
resolution imaging and so forth and
spectroscopy and also peering into the
dark ages cosmologically are there
before we move on to technology
questions are there other science
targets that are especially uh
appropriate for building facilities on
the moon whether or not in astronomy
well here's the major science Target
which is an extension of the Dark Ages
search suppose um we do go there we're
building experiments together actually
there are one two they're already job
we'll come to but suppose we start
getting data from these many hydrogen
clouds from the beginning
well the beautiful thing about this is
there are so many of these clouds I mean
when we do surveys of galaxies to get
information about the size and the
universe the content and the
acceleration of the universe expansion
and all this stuff we're dealing with
billions of galaxies maybe um if we can
start harvesting the data from
the dark clouds will suddenly be getting
trillions of clouds in our surveys now
that means immensely more inflammation
which you can then analyze to do
cosmology with
and so our cosmology now is limited as
we said the beginning to one or two
percent accuracy but with all this you
know let's say a hundred thousand
million times more information even will
suddenly be able to get an accuracy that
surpasses that by a hundred thousand I
mean frankly of a percent accuracy in
determining that the puzzling parameters
of cosmology so that's the dream and
there's one more aspect of this which to
me is even more incredible is the only
robust test of the inflation Theory
okay is that the fluctuations from the
beginning do have these primordial Wells
and twists and things that's common to
authorism inflation this is not just the
gravity waves that it's whole other
story yeah but this is just intrinsic to
the fluctuations and the only way you
can ever see those is we have enough
sensitivity and so it's it's a seems to
be true that with these telescopes on
The Far Side of the Moon if we make them
large enough we'll have the sensibility
to actually pin down the details of
whether inflation actually occurred or
not and we're able to test one of its I
think most robust predictions which are
which are these um what we call
non-gaussianarities from the beginning
yeah that's a goal for me a major car I
guess I shouldn't pass up the
opportunity while we have you here I did
talk to Adam Reese our our joint
colleague a while back about the Hubble
tension about the apparent disagreement
between measuring the Hubble parameter
using early things like the microwave
background versus using more nearby
stars and galaxies uh apparently it's
still a looming issue out there do you
have a favorite prognostication as to
what's going to happen is there new
physics lurking there or do we have to
get our measurements in order
well I I discuss this a lot with Adam
but let me just say that I I'm very
concerned that
um all the data that comes from using um
Stellar indicator Supernova indicators
which Adam is the world's expert on Etc
um it's a little bit like um climbing a
distance ladder to get to the things far
away and you can never be very certain
about the first rung on that letter it
might be unstable you might fall down
right so now many of us are completely
certain it's a robust very solid letter
but nevertheless it is an indirect way
of getting far away ideally what we'd
like are what we call geometrical
indicators uh which um don't rely on on
going up a ladder but I just erect
measures of distance and I would say
until we get those securely in place the
me the jury is out because there are
worries just about the observational
issues and systematics
um that come from from using experience
and uh you know other types of stars to
build your distance leather so I I think
we're still beginning to explore the
natures of the environments of these
different distance indicators we don't
all agree with each other and uh I don't
I'm not convinced that we have a robust
uh forward
uh way there I'd rather wait until
we get some geometrical indicator which
will come in the next 10 years okay very
good thank you for that update so let's
let's be much more down to earth I mean
we're both theoretical physicists at
heart but uh in writing this book I
forgot to mention you've written a book
I will mention it in the intro I promise
but back to the moon the next giant leap
for humankind you must have dug into
some of the technological challenges
involved with literally going to the
Moon I mean you've already mentioned
very briefly that you you envisioned
both human beings building things but
also robots building things is it going
to be almost all one or the other what
do you imagine to be the mix of people
and construction and so forth
uh well it's it's such a rapidly
involving situation I I would have said
um a year ago
that um if you you could do a lot with
robots but any humans very close by to
guide them because a robot
um has to respond instantaneously
but what's happened last year has amazed
me because the development of artificial
intelligence is such an amazing speed so
now I do not quite see what the limits
are actually of robotic deployment of
telescopes on the moon for example right
so basically if you if you put a robot
on the moon with a certain goal we're
more confident now that it could figure
out how to solve puzzles maybe than we
were a year ago that's right how to you
know if you see if it's a crevice in
front of it you know uh you know it
might take seconds to get instructions
from the earth and what to do next but I
suspect before very long we'll figure
out ways of having um you know
self-guiding robots that can cope with
any any conditions they come across so
that that's what I think is a an amazing
area that's developing so rapidly it's
hard to predict where we're going
it's easy for me in my brain as a as a a
very long-term science fiction reader to
imagine robots building telescopes on
the moon
um is that do we really appreciate what
the challenges are there
well uh
you know I I think you need human
intervention right basically because
um there are just so many surprises that
um you have to have someone on you know
on the spot to look out for but again I
don't see what the limits are for the
robots at this point so remember we're
forecasting
um what's going to happen probably on a
20 or 30-year time scale with these big
telescope projects and the rage at which
AI has developed so rapidly in the past
two years and how on Earth can we
forecast where we may be and you know
but here's time it's all crazy yeah so
what what is the biggest challenge
besides the fact that it's far away I
mean obviously you're in vacuum there's
dust uh the dust is there's no
atmosphere but there is dust right right
so let's talk about the Dust so lunar
regolith is everywhere it's
um
uh
uh very abrasive dust actually so it's
not good for telescope mirrors so
we will need to think of ways to um
um Shield the bearer somewhere from the
dust now one interesting aspect is this
that um the dust is
um photo charged by ultraviolet light
um and levitate okay kind of the charge
okay so it rise in the day but at night
time it falls down
so the hope is that you know
normally dark crater
Dust We much less of a problem which is
why you probably want to go there
rather than in some random place on the
moon to go to telescopes so I don't know
I mean that that's that's something
we're discussing and obviously there are
also ways of
self-repairing devices
um that can self anneal Etc to you know
to develop protection against us too so
I I think these problems are going to be
surmountable by our Engineers have we
learned a lot from the experience with
Martian Rovers
um that I cannot say
um we've certainly experienced um
micrometeorite impacts on the web
telescope already and that has not been
a major disaster and one might expect
similar issues on the moon so I think
you should be able to either experience
to cope with that too what about Moon
Quakes are those a an issue
so moonquakes uh uh are known to be far
far weaker than earthquakes
um by an enormous factor and so they're
they're often caused by um asteroid
impacts or some minor settling of the
moon but
um they're relatively uh
minor things I don't think they're any
danger at all the one area where they've
come up recently has been we wanted to
actually one of the first things we'll
do on the moon is put down seismometers
in various places now Apollo did this
but we now have much better ideas and
models and building seismometers and the
reason we want to do this is that we
want to measure the shaking of the Moon
because that's basically like a gigantic
um gravity wave detector you know so you
imagine
um right now we've measured gravity
waves with um basically having laser
beams that are four kilometers long our
future ones will have 40 kilometers long
we measure the shaking of these beams by
a passing Gravelly wave from merging
black holes well the moon four thousand
kilometers you can certainly do
something different okay you can measure
lower frequency gravity equations just
like longer together instances and you
can measure the inspiringly you've got
black holes that come together to give
you the uh the ones we've seen already
so it's a whole new chapter on gravity
wave astronomy which we'll do with
seismometers on the moon and and various
devices based on them Etc which are
planning to and that's again fairly
known technology so it shouldn't be too
hard and I think that'll be one of the
early things we do on this on the moon I
had not ever heard that idea that's a
wonderful one is it clearly Superior in
some ways to just building satellites
and bouncing lasers between them
um it's complementary so right now our
best satellite a main satellite project
has a separation of the satellites of a
million kilometers New Balance Ladies
and so this is a very very different
frequency from the one measure on the
moon so after that we're debating uh
formation flying of satellites with a
few thousand kilometers separation and
that would be much more or less
equivalent of what we do on the moon so
it'll be a complementary activity to
what we do in the movie actually the
satellites but that's a future thing too
all right so we've listed uh there the
Moon is far away it's cold there's no
atmosphere there's dust there's
moonquakes are there is there any other
worries that uh we haven't anticipated
yet
well I you have to support people of
course and um uh we need them somewhere
and I think one of the big worries is
going to be um the physical state of
people that um suffer long stays on the
moon this is one of the reasons we want
to put them in in a space station around
the moon so we've done that on the earth
and I don't know how well people realize
this but when our
um astronauts come back from the space
station after a six-month stay there if
you if you probably have noticed you see
them in chairs they are not able to walk
very well yeah and I'm not sure what
other problems they may have but um you
know on the moon there could be longer
stays it could be worse so I think we
have things like this to learn from and
understand much better and of course
some issues about radiation exposure Etc
like that it'll all be far far worse on
Mars don't worry about that the Moon is
an easy step forward people do it as
long as I agree about it in the science
fiction stories our space stations
always have rotations so they can mimic
artificial gravity but as far as I know
that's not in the plans of any current
NASA program or anything like that I
think that's right that's right you
don't really want to do that for an
opening space station probably nature
okay
and do you I mean how much of the
program of doing astronomy on the moon
and other things is beholden to a larger
program of getting people there on a
regular basis
so it's all part of the same story so I
think the here is why
I think um
we have to be patient we have to realize
that science astronomy telescopes are
not at the head of the queue for the
moment but on the other hand that gives
them an enormous Advantage because we're
going to build infrastructure here for
the moment not just the orbiting space
station but um uh it's having Luna
Rovers doing construction on the moon
etc etc
um and all of this will take some
enormous budget which is being planned
and it's partly spurred on by
International rivalry right okay because
uh it's clear that uh
you know if the US doesn't do this China
will etc etc and um it's not even clear
where we're young we have to have better
coordination of course as whole of the
story but anyway
um
all of this will be very expensive so if
I were to imagine spending a few percent
of the cost of the infrastructure on
science that would be enough to build
all the telescopes I've talked about
and the reason I'm confident of that is
let me give you an example uh
the space station and the shuttle
were built at some you know
multi-billion dollar whatever expense
and we would never have had the Hubble
Space Telescope uh without those things
okay Hubble was a few percent of the
total right that we put into all that
other infrastructure in space and you
can make a similar arguments that are
moving all the telescopes I've talked
about will be a few percent of the total
of this amazing story that we're going
to build on the moon and do things on
the moon so it seems to me it's not a
little crazy to imagine big science
projects that they're cheap relatively
speaking this is probably an unfair
question but is there any hope for
international cooperation here rather
than rivalry
I think it's essential all right we we
better have this because even right now
I think we're very worried NASA is very
worried for example
um but they know the Chinese are putting
science experiments on the moon
um probably anything on a faster time
scale than National is although although
there's been the competition between the
two and the worry is that you know if
the Chinese are there first they say I
want this crater for my experiment you
know and that's a desirable Creator
there aren't that many dark Raiders
there are order 50 or something I mean
you know who takes what the choice real
estate I haven't also told you this that
these dark craters some of them have
immensely high rims and those rims are
always important in sunlight permanent
sunlight because they're so high they
see the Sun so they're the places where
you can pipe in solar power into your
dark crater ideal for doing experiments
ideal for many other things too since
competition for them so I hope we don't
results you know I got there first
that's mine we after coordination we've
done this in the past the best example
is Antarctica I don't know how well
known this is but there are I think some
70 different research stations in
different countries in in Antarctica all
very nicely allocated no rivalry no Wars
um
but we've done that we know how to do
this of course the commercial Stakes
there are much much less than what a
waitress on the moon so it's all it's a
different ball game so but I hope we can
have something similar to guidance let's
fill in a little bit the commercial
Stakes because I'm interested in the
motivation for private companies or
individuals to go there also I mean we
hear talk about mining
um tourism and so forth do you have a
feeling for how realistic that is or
what what are the resources up there in
the Moon that you can't just get easier
down here on Earth
so the resources are this that the moon
has been bombarded by
asteroids and meteorites over billions
of years and now this happened on the
earth too but they burn up in the
Earth's atmosphere on the moon they
cover the surface with valuable raw
materials
and so the moon has enormously larger
reserves of rarer Earth elements like
europium Vanadium Etc
um that are essential
for much of what we do on the earth now
in terms of high technology
the screen still you know winning loss
whatever all sorts of things on the
earth we're running out of supplies we
know that European for example has
probably 1 000 years as a surprise
either rare Earths a little longer but
on the moon we have enough to keep us
going for a million years thousands of
times more resources and so it's
incredibly interesting Target for the
mining companies you you know that as
resources get lower the price starts up
so it's going to become incredibly
expensive scene on the earth what is
more it's even worse than that because
mining Rare Earth is a really toxic
process and right now China dominates
the rare earth industry mostly for that
reason they would take the risks now
it's not clear and they also have the
dominant reserves on the earth so there
are two reasons there so going to the
moon will open up new possibilities the
mining it will be something that will
last for thousands of years to be a
major investment and I it's such an
incredible attraction to the big mining
companies that um I I think that we're
going to do that regardless yeah but if
we mine on them we have to survey the
moon and that will that involves a whole
other story but that will be what's
going to be happening the next 10 years
choosing the best mining sites on them
I I guess maybe I just have trouble
imagining this but how do you ship all
that stuff back from the moon to the
earth that sounds very expensive
um well not really because right now
we're going through this dramatic leap
in space cargo development
um where you know we had many launches
at the 110 level capacity we're in the
process of um building two one has flown
successfully the NASA SLS the star a
Starship has not yet flown successfully
but both will have of order 100 ton
payload on what is more a Starship when
it does eventually work will be unlike
uh the NASA a spacecraft recyclable
reusable yeah well it's just bring down
enormously the payload cost so
um I I don't think that's going to be a
real problem we'll be able to over the
next decades have efficient ways of um
shipping whatever we need back to Earth
that'll be some price attached but it'll
be nevertheless uh a source of enormous
for the mining companies in principle
so if you had to guess you don't have to
but if you wanted to
um when would you anticipate the first
telescope
seeing first light on the moon
well
um actually in three years time okay
good so let me explain that so um not
necessarily
uh the most useful first light but this
is a radio telescope and so
um uh two projects are under planning
now to go up in 2026 one of them is a
single
antenna
um it's designed by NASA at the
department of energy and it will go on
the far side and we'll look for the
shadow of the dark agent so that's the
first thing we're doing a simple dipole
antenna on The Far Side of the Moon the
Chinese already landed something on the
far side the first such antenna but it
didn't bring back data because the local
electronics were so noisy it was
designed badly they didn't mask that out
but the new instrument built in this
case by NASA will solve that problem the
only difficulty is that um it'll go to
The Far Side they'll land it there
but its battery power is limiting so it
doesn't have large enough batteries to
survive
um more than one night on the moon which
is 14 days long so the problem is that
it won't get enough data so we'll need
to we have to develop power you know
battery power and we're not quite there
yet meanwhile on exactly the same time
scale
a Chinese have solved this problem
so they're sending a flotilla of nine
spacecraft to orbit around the Moon one
Mothership and eight smaller antennas on
10e and they basically orbit the Moon
far side to near side every two hours so
they take their data on the far side
they fly in from Nation so they act
together like an interferometer or a
giant radio telescope and they take
their data then radio back to Earth so
that it seems to me has the best chance
of getting the first science signal
From The Far Side of the Moon and that's
going to happen soon and then on the
longer time scale we have a much more
dramatic projects in radio astronomy we
know we lead much more than 9 and 10
equal lead hundreds maybe even thousands
so we're designing products to do just
that on the first side of the moon but
that's going to take much longer of
course
I love the idea of the simple cheap fast
uh radio telescope because once there is
any working model it becomes much more
real in people's minds right it will it
will help Inspire them to the next step
exactly that's right and that's the
beauty of of one of the current NASA
programs where they they they they have
commercial spacecraft which carry small
payloads and they've been able to sell
projects to other countries you know
that I mentioned there was an Israeli
project a UAE project also uh and
they'll be continuing
um to land small lunar Rovers in these
cases on the moon that's the immediate
goal India is very much involved too
they want to do surveying of the Moon
with their next generation of of lunar
orbitals so it's a huge an interesting
competition now it's interesting how it
it comes and goes it was 50 years and
then we went quiet and now we're back
again it seems like uh in with Earnest
but I mean maybe for the very last
question uh let's reflect a little bit
on
how the scientific Community goes about
things like this I mean these are
obviously very big ambitious goals that
you were discussing here I I worry that
sometimes scientists are almost too
cynical in a in an attempt to be
realistic like they they hear these
giant plans and of course if you're the
one proposing them you'll be very
enthusiastic but others are going to be
like Ah that's you know a load of hot
air we'll never get there you know how
how well does a scientific Community do
in coming together
over these big plans and are there ways
we can do better
um right now I would say the scientific
Community is doing a slightly better job
than
um
our logical communities in in um
learning for experiments on the moon we
have conferences in which um
participants include different space
agencies not just the us but also I was
one recently with both China and India
very well represented
describing their their um their projects
for the Muna lunar astronomy on the ball
start so all of this is happening
um I think overall we still need better
coordination
um internationally to make sure that
when the commercial aspects which are
driving all of this will really get
under the way there is some a suitably
peaceful
strategy for um negotiating for a
sharing
um International coordination right now
we don't have that I I I think we have a
window maybe a few years to develop this
uh as the political situation improves
perhaps we'll get there uh right now it
seems impossible to imagine this
happening but
um I'm optimistic what we want to do is
avoid the wild west basically on the
moon that's the uh that's the hope of
Summer I think I think it's good to be
optimistic about these things certainly
it's a it's an ambitious program and I'm
very excited about everything you've
told us so Joe silk thanks very much for
being on the mindscape podcast
it's been a real pleasure for you thank
you
[Music]
mama